when you start a business with an exit
strategy in mind it means you were
setting out to play the finite game
which means you will put lipstick on
that pig right you may have a weak
culture but you're gonna prioritize
making them the numbers look good for
the seller for the buyer rather than for
actually building a strong culture which
is something they can't see and it's
harder for them to evaluate right we've
all seen it right and we see what
happens when companies get sold they go
right very often or some turnaround
person comes in and makes everybody hate
their lives and you know but it that's
my little secret question when somebody
wants me to get involved in their
business I would say what's your exit
strategy and if they have one I'm not
interested now I don't have a problem
with an exit but an exit should happen
organically you've been doing it for
twenty years
you're tired bad enough it's time to
exit but you're gonna hand over really
strong culture with a really wonderful
group of people who you're gonna care
about and everybody's been taking care
of and hopefully you're gonna sell it to
somebody that may not be the highest
bidder but it's the best person to
continue to carry your torch into the
future right so again it goes back to
the previous question I don't know when
it started that we should only start
businesses to sell them I mean and if
you do do that and this is I don't have
a problem with people who play by the
finite mindset by the way just stop
pretending that you're not like I'm
tired of companies that put their where
purpose-driven and we care about people
you don't know you know I don't have any
problem if you put on your website we
don't give a rat's ass about purpose
we're not buying one to give one to
anybody we don't really we're gonna put
cheaper ingredients so we can make
squeeze and extra penny on the margins
we don't care we're just maximizing
profit take it or leave it I actually
don't have a problem with that because
then at least I know what I'm buying and
now I actually have the choice if I want
to buy into that or not right but don't
pretend and lie to me don't pretend and
lie to me tell me that you're Purpose
Driven and you care about people before
profit I've never met a CEO who doesn't
care about their people right there
number one growth number two my
shareholder number three my people see I
care that means there's at least two
other things that come more important
than the very people who helped you
build your wealth right so I don't
actually have a problem with it just be
honest just be honest and I think
everybody I think too many people lie
about that they actually are playing in
there for the game where they're not so
and I think it's terrible that we're
teaching people to start businesses so
that they can sell them because again if
you play by that mindset you're going to
make very different decisions about your
people your product your ingredients
even how to treat your customer over if
you're building a business with an
infinite mindset
[Music]